My question is why was Muhammad fearful
when angel Gabriel appeared to him in
the cave? Sorry, can you repeat your
question? What? Why did prophet Muhammad
Why was he fearful when angel Gabriel
appeared to him in the cave? If I heard
your question correctly, why did Prophet
Muhammad fear? Yes, when he saw
Archangel Gabriel. Yes, very good
question. This was as a good question
that when Archangel
Gabriel the first time when the first
revelation was revealed to him, why was
he afraid? Because he didn't expect
it. He never expected that some angel
will come. And if you read the
historical books and the hadith of the
prophet, it says that when prophet
Muhammad peace be upon there, he was
contemplating and praying to God in the
cave. The archangel Gabriel comes and
tells him read. So he was shocked who's
this person asking to read and again he
says the prophet replies I'm not
learning. But um in the Bible when
people had encounters with angel the
angel reassured them not to fear because
they sent God has sent them. Very good.
So why was he not given any reassurance
not to be afraid? A very good question.
He went on and um instead he told his
wife to cover him because he had a lot
of fear. But in the Bible when people
had encounters with angels, the angels
reassured them not to fear. Because in 2
Timothy vers 7 it says God did not give
us a spirit of fear but of power, love,
and a sound mind. So why can God allow
us to have fear? It doesn't make sense
if he was from God. If that angel was
from God. Very good. Sister asked her a
good question. She's saying that in the
Bible there are many instant many
instances where an angel appears to
prophets or to other human beings. They
tell them I angel don't get afraid.
Correct? Yes. That is also mentioned in
the Quran.
That's also mentioned in the Quran that
when angel appears to Abraham Alisam and
to other prophets they and the angel
says don't get afraid. Correct. Here
archangel Gabriel didn't tell to prophet
don't get
scared. I'll complete this prophecy
about when the archangel Gabriel tells
to prophet Muhammad Ikra the prophet is
scared. You know why? He was unlearned.
Because let me complete then you can
when when the archangel Gabriel says
read he says I'm not learning why this
is the fulfillment of the prophecy in
the Bible. If you read the Bible in the
book of Isaiah chapter number 29 verse
number
12 it will be said to him who's
unlearned. This is a prophecy mentioned
in the Old Testament about the last and
final messenger prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him. In the book of Isaiah
chapter number 29 verse number 12 it is
said the book will be given to him who's
unlearned and I it will be
said read this I pray and he will reply
I am not learned. So this is the
fulfillment of the prophecy mentioned in
the previous scriptures of the old
testament. So even in in the Quran and
the tapir of the Quran when this first
revelation was come came prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him was scared.
Before this he was not the messenger of
God. This is the first revelation he
gets at the age of 40. Before this he
was a very pious person but the
prophethood wasn't bestowed on him. So
moment the first time the angel comes
he's afraid like a normal human being.
Yes. The angel comes to you or to me
also we'll be scared. So at that time he
was a normal human being. The first time
when he comes and when the angel asks
him read he thinks he's asking him to
read and he's not he's unlearning. So he
replies by saying maari I'm not
learning. So again he repeats
readkra read ma. The third time when he
says read ikra has got three meanings.
One is read one is recite one is
proclaim. So then he realizes oh he's
asking him to repeat. So for repeating
you don't have to be learning. Correct
repeating you don't have to be learned.
Then he
says read, recite, proclaim in the name
of thy lord who created who created the
human beings from something which clings
a leak substance. So when he says the
full verse then prophet Muhammad
realizes peace be upon him that what the
archangel Gabriel wants is not that he
should read but he should repeat and he
repeats
it and then the first five verses of the
Quran was revealed when he comes back
home being a human being he's shivering
then his wife has a khad may Allah be
pleased with her she wraps him up and
says don't worry you are a man of God no
harm will come to you so this is a human
being so what is wrong in that if
someone sees an angel like and gets
scared there's nothing wrong in it but
if the angel keeps on coming again and
again and then if he gets scared then
you can object the first time it's
normal he's a human being so for me he's
a human being he's not god so if he gets
afraid then it's normal many of the
messengers when they see angels they get
scared
when Archangel Gabriel keeps on coming
again and again, then he's not scared.
So why? So what is wrong in that? Like
um Mary and Zachariah, the encounter
with Mary and Zachariah, the encounter
with angel Gabriel, it was different
with the encounter with angel um with
Mohamad. like after Mary and Zachariah
had an encounter with um angel Gabriel
after that after the encounter they did
not have fear when the angel left unlike
Muhammad after the encounter he
continued to have fear and uh God cannot
he doesn't give us a spirit of
fear asked me the question when Mary
peace be upon
when she encountered with the angel and
Zakariah peace be upon him when he
encountered with the angel they didn't
feel fear so it's not to feel fear is
not something haram it's not something
wrong it's human being for me for me it
is normally the human being some get
fear some don't get fear here we come to
know that the first time when the angel
appears there's a difference between
prophet Muhammad peace be upon upon him
and prophet Zachariah and Mary. First of
all, mother Mary was not a prophet. Yes.
Correct. Mhm. They give glad tidings
then they go. Here you understand it's
not necessary that if one messenger
feels scared it is wrong or one
messenger is not scared it is correct.
Every messenger is different. For
example, prophet Moses spoke to God face
to face.
Abraham did not speak. So does that make
Abraham a lesser prophet?
No. Jesus Christ peace be upon him did
not speak God face to face. Does it make
him a lesser prophet? No. No. Quran says
that that Abraham is a friend of God.
It's a title. Does it mean the other
messengers are enemies of God? No. So
these are titles given. Every prophet is
unique by himself. We'll only object if
he does something which is
unnatural or something which is not
correct or something which is sinful. So
to get scared it is not sinful at all.
So for me it is normal. I being a doctor
I being intelligent person if one man is
scared one man is not scared it make
that doesn't make him lower high. Yes.
But but what you have to see after that?
Yes. After that, more prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him kept on interacting
with Archangel Gabriel. There is no
prophet who interacted with Archangel
Gabriel as much as Prophet Muhammad did.
Do you know any messenger any messenger
Zakaria Mary peace be upon her and him
did they interact as much as Prophet
Muhammad? No. So that that so this
interaction depends upon Allah. So if
you see Archangel Gabriel, he was chosen
by almighty God especially to give the
revelation
to to Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
to others he came less number of time to
Prophet Muhammad he came more number of
time. So for me if you see the full life
of course prophet Muhammad peace be upon
interacted more number of times he spoke
to him many more times if you see the
hadith multiple more time than any other
messenger. Why? Because he was the last
and final messenger. So first time if a
messenger sees an angel and he's afraid
it's normal. He's a human being. There's
nothing wrong with that. Why do you
object? What is wrong?
Like you no is it a sin? No, it's not a
sin. But after the encounter, you should
not have that extreme fear if it is from
God. If you have an encounter with God
like he has to assure you that do not be
afraid but there is no problem at all
this because this shows that prophet
Muhammad was a human being. People
should not think he's God otherwise like
Christians people will start thinking
prophet Muhammad is God. So I feel it's
good. So if a human being is afraid and
then believe there's no problem at all
is a human being like you and me. So all
the prophets are human being. So you
putting condition that you should not
get scared is your condition. It's not
the condition of God. Do you understand?
So for me if any human being yes if he's
God cannot get scared. So this proves
that he's not
God and that's the reason in our kalma
when we
say Muhammad Abdulu that is the servant
of Allah. So all these acts prove that
he's a human being. So I feel this is an
excellent example that all the
messengers of God they were human beings
they were not God. Otherwise like many
Christian they wrongly call God Jesus as
God. Sister do you believe Jesus is God?
Yes. Can you point out a single
unequivocal statement anywhere in the
Bible where Jesus Christ peace be upon
himself says that I am God or where he
says worship me? There's no direct
passage that he says that I'm God
worship me. There's no direct passage. I
can't hear you sister. There's no direct
um verse that Jesus says I am God
worship you. Very good. Very good. But
he refers to himself. That mean sister
is agreeing there is not a single
unequivocal statement anywhere in the
Bible where Jesus Christ peace be upon
himself says I am God. Yet you worship.
That means you're not following Jesus
peace be upon him. Jesus Christ peace be
upon him said I can of my own self do
nothing. That means a human being as I
hear I judge and my judgment is just for
I seek not my will but the will of my
father the same condition what that
young boy gave I didn't understand he
was problem you know but in many verses
he says I am God not directly but um
like he says if you love me you'll keep
my
commandments in sister you have to keep
the commandments of all the messengers
why only Jesus peace be upon him of
Abraham of Moses. Don't you have to
follow? Was Abraham a messenger of God
or not? Was Moses a prophet of God or
not? He was. So, don't you have to keep
the commandment? Yes. So, what is the
difference? Even Jesus was a messenger
peace be upon him. We love him. We
respect him. But we don't worship him. I
worship you.
Why do you worship him? Yes.
And
um another question. Now you opened your
book. Okay. Read from your book.
What do you want to read? Another
question.
Um why when you pray um in Islam you
have to face a specific direction or and
you have to pray in
Arabic. Why is Arabic
the root language?
Sister, I've heard your question. You
said that when you pray, you pray in a
particular direction. Yes. So why do you
play in the direction is a question.
Yes. Very good question. Sister has a
question that when we Muslims pray, we
face towards the
cabba. Why do we face the cabba? Because
kaba is our kibla. Kibla means
direction. Why do we face the kibla is
the question. Because we in Islam
believe in unity. We don't believe in
division. So today suppose we all of us
want to pray here in this tent. Where
will we pray? East, west, north or
south? You will say west, he will say
east, he will say north. Where do we
pray? Different direction. So for
unity Allah says when you pray, you face
the direction of the cabba. It's a verse
of the Quran in surah bakar chapter
number two. So we face the cabba for
unity not that we worship the cabba.
Some people may think that we worship
the cabba. No Muslim ever worship the
kaba. Do you understand? Yes. Cabba is
the kibla. Kibla means direction. We
believe in unity. When we go for Hajj to
Makkah, we circumambulate around the
cabba. We circumambulate around the
cabba because every circular center to
testify there is one
god and the second califf of
Islam. That is hazumar. May Allah be
pleased with him. He said pointing at
this black
stone and he said this black stone can
neither benefit me can neither harm me.
I'm kissing the black stone only because
my prophet kissed it. Otherwise this
stone cannot benefit me, cannot harm me.
This proves that no Muslim ever
worshiped the stone. Furthermore, at the
time of the prophet, there were many of
the companions of the prophet. They
stood on the cabba and gave the
azan. They stood on the cabba and gave
the azan. Will any idol worshipper stand
on the cabba, the idol he or she is
woriing?
Will any idol worshipper I'm asking you
a question stand will any idol
worshipper stand on the idol he or she
is worshiping
no no so that proves the Muslims don't
worship the cabba we don't worship it's
only a kibla we believe in unity other
will be chaos you will say pray east he
will say west some will say north some
will say south so for unity everyone in
the world faces kaba makkah and we pray
in mandar Hope that answers the
question. So you're saying like
Christians, okay, we pray facing
anywhere at any time. Okay. Like
Christians, it's like you're saying we
have confusion because we don't pray
facing a specific direction or Yeah,
of course there's no direction. How
there's no because you have the freedom.
There's no unity. Some Christians pay
south, some pay west, some pay. No
unity. All directions are different.
Okay, that's your problem, not my
problem.
Okay, it's it's fine. It's fine. That's
the reason that's the reason Jesus
Christ peace be upon him said in the
Gospel of John chapter number 16 verse
number 11 to 14, I have many things to
say unto you, but he cannot bear them
now. For he when the spirit of truth
shall come, he shall guide you onto all
truth. He shall not speak of himself.
All that he hear shall he speak. He
shall show you things to come. Who is
Prophet Muhammad talking about? The
spirit of truth is the Holy Spirit. Ah,
Holy Spirit. Okay. She's saying about
sister gave a very good reply. Prophet
Muhammad is talking about Holy Spirit.
What does it say? I have many things to
say unto you. You cannot bear them now.
He went the spirit of thall come.
Sister, the Bible says the Holy Spirit
was there when Jesus was born. Yes or
no? The Holy Spirit.
Sister, just answer my question. The
Bible, doesn't it say when Jesus Christ
was born, peace be upon him, the Holy
Spirit was there? When Jesus was born,
when Jesus Christ was born to Mother
Mary, the Holy Spirit was there, right?
So, here's the prophecy saying, I have
many things to say unto you, but he
cannot bear them now. For he when the
spirit of tr, it is listen, he first is
talking about a male, not to a spirit.
No, in that verse wait listen listen let
me complete and then you can reply
number one he refers to a man not a
spirit he when he when the spirit of
truth shall come he shall guide you onto
all truth he shall not speak of himself
all that he shall he speak four five
times he it's the holy spirit holy
spirit is not called he because wait let
me complete first why you interjecting
I'll give you a chance to speak
He is referring to male a man. Number
two, the prophecy says when the prophet
will
come, the holy spirit was already there
when Jesus Christ peace be upon him was
born. So your analysis of holy spirit is
totally wrong. He shall speak of not of
himself. All that he shall he speak.
That means whatever god we know in the
Quran and in the hadith the words were
sent by angel Gabriel. What you said he
repeated as the words were put in the
mouth. Where were words put into the
mouth of the Holy Spirit? Nowhere in the
Bible it says that. Here it says all
that he hear shall he speak. Talking
about prophet
Muhammad. He shall glorify me. Did the
Holy Spirit glorify Jesus? No. Where?
Where did the Holy Spirit glorify Jesus?
Where? That means you're not reading the
Bible. Number one, Holy Spirit was
already there when Jesus before Jesus
was born, peace be upon him. The Holy
Spirit was there when Jesus lived on the
face of the earth. This prophecy is
talking about someone to come in the
future. So, it can't be Holy Spirit.
Number two, he's used four, five times.
It cannot be a spirit. Number three,
words were put in his mouth. There are
no words put in the mouth of Holy
Spirit. Number four, he shall glorify
Jesus Christ peace be upon him. Where
are these four things mentioned in the
Bible? Then an agreed holy spirit. Okay.
The god is it mentioned in the Bible all
these four things.
All these four things which are
mentioned in the prophecy does not be
the holy spirit. Just because your
father your church has said you are
repeating it blindly. No you have to
think
logically. Was the Holy Spirit there or
not? He was there. He was there before
Jesus was born, peace be upon him. He
was there in the womb of mother Mary. He
was there when Jesus was born, peace be
upon him. He was there when Jesus lived.
So this is not talking about Holy
Spirit. Someone is misguiding you. That
means you're not reading the Bible
correctly. He when he comes is talking
about someone who's not present. The
Holy Spirit at first when Jesus was born
was within him with him but after when
he left he said that the spirit will be
within you. So it is only it doesn't
send it doesn't say that. You're
misquotising the Bible. The Bible says
Jesus Christ said I have many things to
say unto you but you cannot bear them
now for he when the spirit of truth
shall come. That mean he cannot be
within him. We refer to otherwise Jesus
is lying. We cannot believe prophet
Jesus can lie. So why you accusing Jesus
Christ peace be upon him of lying? I
will not tolerate that. My prophet Jesus
peace be upon him. He's my prophet. You
cannot accuse him of lying. You are
putting your own words. Jesus Christ
peace be upon him said when he
comes he shall guide you to all truth.
The Holy Spirit was already there. So
why you are misunderstanding Jesus
Christ peace be upon him. He's talking
about the prophecy of prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him. No no no. We refer
the Godhead, God the Father, God the
Son, and God the Holy Spirit to be
referred to them as he he the persona he
where he where is it mentioned God the
father holy spirit to me which of the
Bible say when Jesus was baptized which
of the Bible says this
okay okay
um I'm giving you chance to reply
because you're not like that young
Correct.
Now I'm trying to explain to you that
Jesus Christ peace be upon him clearly
mentioned in the Bible about the
prophecy of prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him. Okay, very clearly. Why don't
you understand? Where does it say Holy
Spirit? Holy Spirit is already there. So
why are you getting misguided?
I'm not misguided.
Hello, it is plain English sister and I
think your English is very good. Not
like that young boy.
Anyway, okay. What's the next question?
So when you go home, you can read
properly. Okay. Okay. Gospel of John
chapter number 16 verse number 11 to 14.
Note it down. Note in your diary. Gospel
of John chapter number 16 verse number
11 to 14.